hello everybody my name is markiplier
Nazz you may have noticed my beautiful
face is not in the top-left corner of
this screen
unfortunately the airline that I went
through decided that it would be a good
idea to smash the webcam I brought into
itty-bitty pieces so I'm gonna be
getting a webcam later today but for now
I thought it would have been appropriate
to play a game that is mainly an
auditory experience this is the devil's
tuning fork and as you can see it is
based almost entirely on sound and it is
modeled after echolocation which is what
bats and other things used to travel
around the world so I just obtained I'm
assuming the devil's tuning fork and
there's a rather disturbing error rabbit
over there huh I couldn't quite
understand what he was saying that
there's no subtitles allowed in this
game at least that's what I saw in the
options menu hello mister bunny how are
you doing Oh
oh I'm so sorry that I disturbed the
monster unfortunately I have to get
through this go to the left mouse button
to charge up and release a concentrated
sound Chbosky woo now there's a little
something-something so this is a game
that I actually found out about a while
ago and the story is that there's been
an epidemic that is causing children Oh
what okay so the the basis is that
there's been an epidemic that causes
children to fall into comas and you are
one of those children can detect
unstable floor panels what in the world
is going on here
okay if you say so I'm gonna take your
word on that one and I see these big old
band-aids on the bow what happened there
I'm sorry I have to admit this sound so
that I can actually make my way through
this maze and I'll get to you in just a
second now I don't know if this could be
quantified as a horror game but it does
seem to have its creepy moments and
we're gonna be guiding through here now
because I am just relying on the power
of my voice I'm gonna try to make this
as elegant a playthrough as I possibly
can oh okay so III just noticed that I
have a bar down on the bottom that I can
actually keep them the eye on and
actually make more pulses come out
you're so alone I have no idea what's
going on there was just a little bit of
backstory but not much okay so I'm
looking for a bell aha
but there we go so the concentrated
birth this is actually interesting like
very very interesting to see because
this is all like a totally forum type
foreign type of game that I'm playing
I've never really encountered anything
like this before
see chart sounds will only reflect off
of mirrors say what oh ah there we are
so I'm really brave did you say I swear
I can barely hear the voices there
oddly enough they're the most inaudible
thing in this game so I need to charge
hit both that and that ah there we go
got it got it got it interesting this is
so like almost magical in a sense
because I I mean there's been mechanics
in games where you can't really see
where you're going but this is this is
an entirely different level there's
something completely different going on
here that I've never ever experienced
before it's more than just being deaf
it's being totally reliant on your sound
is the opposite of being deaf it's like
you were only able to hear I'm sorry
okay how do I do that
I keep getting flipped around my Mouse's
mom the mouse that I got is a cheap one
here in whoa tribulations that's another
word for fear is it time for the [ __ ]
or to arrive
yeah aside from getting a new mouse and
a new webcam that's pretty much all I
need to get set up
okay that was mistake Elisa's forgiving
on that front
I like the music I gotta say I mean now
you would you would think that a game
that was based on an audio primarily
would have good music I mean not good
music in the sense of like disco
dodgeball which was just completely
bonkers and unimaginably fun whoa I'm
sorry who [ __ ] who wretch you're scared
miss I don't even think that's a word
little kid there okay so I need to find
a way to oh man I'd almost barked that
one up Ark going up I have no idea so I
need to find a way to get up there but I
can't get up there oh these voices just
bouncing off the walls and creeping I'm
wearing I have my very good very
expensive headphones so the way this
sounds playing to me may not come a cut
up I am busy right now may not come
across for you because it's only able to
render in stereo and I can only capture
it in stereo but it's it the sounds are
entirely swirling around my head if you
want to play this game it is free the
link is in the description below and I
think you have to play it oh there we go
that's the one I was looking for okay so
I need to wait for that one you guys
have to play this and play with a good
set of headphones if you can find it the
it's totally disorienting because I'm
hearing things behind me around me
swirling around my head and I don't it
gives this constant sense that I have no
idea where I am like I forgot that I was
doing the low pulse when I should have
been doing the high pulse the high post
lets me see much much more okay this was
a oho I thought I wasn't
I'm gonna try a little kitty I'm gonna
try real hard god that is freely cool
ass apologize for not using my
high-intensity bursts for a while there
I was just trying to make my way the low
one is only for finding the flawed tiles
whoa I'm sorry I have no idea what is
going on there's a lot of voices going
on now all over the place
it is so disorienting like it's not just
disorienting in that I can't see all the
time it's disorienting that the sounds
that I'm cluing in do are just going
bonkers everywhere it's insanity
do you go crazy playing a game like this
for too long okay those are great those
are completely blocked off I really wish
I had a better mouse because right now
it just keeps flipping me at random just
to see like right there it's just it's
either a bad mouse or a bad mat I can't
seem to get it stable um okay I see so
there's just completely I got to go back
a bit that's what I got to do I gotta
like alternate the pulses so that I can
actually see where I need to go there we
go I have no idea little kid frankly I'm
pretty lost myself whoa hey whoa stop
flipping me I don't think that that's
the game's fault I think that is purely
this five-dollar Mouse that I picked up
what is going on over there
my god I have no idea I'm totally lost
at first I thought it was just gonna be
something where I thought it was just
gonna be something where you know the
kids were in a coma and I had to try to
find my way out of the coma but this is
just this is ridiculous I have no idea
what to go not ridiculous in a bad way
than the one saying I'm just completely
flabbergasted as to what I am supposed
to do hello hello little child I will
protect you I see you so how am I going
to book look at that and there was
another one over there but I don't know
I gotta be watchful since Eddie died who
who's supposed to die alright I'm way
off target you'd if there we go God he
got it got it
oh no no well I barely found the hard
way to do it bouncing this off of that
one too there but that was not the
appropriate response apparently don't
worry kid I got you okay didn't hear a
word you said but I'm gonna assume that
you whoa my god no way
ah oh my god I'm sorry kid I'm sorry kid
I'm coming to get you oh good golly
thinks it's pop out of the darkness okay
gonna make it gonna make it good okay
all right we're good
also I don't know how long this game is
I don't expect it to be like a
full-fledged feature-length game I only
intend to do one video on this subject
but man this world is interesting I'm
guessing the tribulation thing was more
due to the fact that the children were
scared as opposed to I was supposed to
be scared there we go come to me
floating magical platform I'm scared
maybe you should toughen up little what
are you a hippo I have no idea what you
are saying and what is the bad thing I
have no idea what you mean by the bad
thing there was just the disease that
was causing people to fall into comas or
children either why can't I go through
this doorway today oh there we go okay I
got it up so I'm guessing that it wants
me to go up I'm trying I have no idea
what that was
I'm over here if I had a piece of
together there are there are both adult
children's voices going on so I'm
assuming of the adults we're running
some sort of an experiment and it either
they experimented on children or it
accidentally spilled over to the town's
children so other than that am I
supposed to hop there
it's need to do double tones oh they
should be much better all right uh damn
what am I supposed to do
what is this room it's like a clock
tower maybe I could whoa what did I do
I didn't even know I did anything I must
be just a genius I automatically solve
puzzles even without looking at them
okay so oh so weird I don't even know if
I can get to that one maybe I could her
looking yeah I made it alright but how
does that help me unless I have to
bounce from here almost almost almost oh
no no no come on okay maybe just bounce
from here no no no no no come on come on
work with me please work with me I need
to recharge my my shooting mechanic oh
damn it I fell through sorry about that
everyone
oh well Lisa didn't spawn me that far
away that was awfully nice about it all
because I reached a checkpoint just then
in there I asked him there we go got it
got it got it got it I had to find out
the correct angle for that because they
got him looped around like such okay so
now that I'm over here I can make my way
finally to that Chum there's another
thing up there
god it's so weird I I'm still not used
to it okay I'm sorry
okay I'm going up now rising to the sky
Oh
dropping off here now there's another
mirror there I don't see the oh it's
right there okay so I need to find a way
to
there's got to be a better angle that I
can get to whoa what did I do
I don't know what I'm doing boink
no no got that one that was easy enough
but the other one up there is gonna
throw me it's so horrible what if that
actually was the way comas worked like
it was like a dream and that you
couldn't remember it afterwards but the
entire time that you were in the coma
you were totally coherent that would be
a nightmare not being able to move your
entire body there's I know there's
conditions like that and stuff like that
happens in them say surgeries where is a
very rare thing where the people will
stay awake did I work okay that got that
one and I would just be absolutely
horrendous especially in a surgery
situation where they're cutting into you
that's just uh couldn't even imagine I
know
bing-bong got it ding dong ding dong
ring a ling ling okay where are you
taking me
I don't know I'm okay so there's another
voice that just said it was killing me
oh this was a mistake
haha where am I rabbi ah no okay Lisa
was kind enough to kill me I guess let
me live beyond my mistake Bingbing
yep I know ok another checkpoint yeah
here we go
and yeah I did he's weird weird whoa
what was I supposed was I supposed to
get off at that other one what's too
close
what are you talking about those that
other voice when the doctor was talking
but it seemed like there were a few
people that he was talking to what is
going on yeah if someone actually if I
don't get it by the time this is all
over if someone actually understands
like the story to this if someone wants
to try to explain it in the comments
below is it's in a way oh oh oh oh oh oh
you almost caught me off guard there in
a way it's actually I don't know I I get
this like for some reason I it's just
constantly just a sad experiment I think
all the music is like in a minor oh this
was a mistake
oh wait I made it god I can never tell
if I'm actually about to fall off or I'm
about to do something correctly okay I
don't know how but I'm gonna try what do
I do
wait I already hit this one right I
think there was another one over there
but I don't know how to get to that one
that one's gonna bounce off to nowhere
Oh what was what did I do it no okay I
was about to say I thought that was
gonna come down to me it was like oh my
god I'm brilliant maybe there's a way to
like get this two mounts up I can angle
it no that's not gonna work what do I do
where do I go
I am entirely lost now I do not see
anything that I need to do also the fact
that if you were in a coma and you were
just walking around in complete darkness
hmm God all that just imagine oh wait no
that one that one that one where does
that one good known that one goes back
it returns it Oh what am I doing here
there's got to be a way to get some
reflection that hits that but I don't
know I I don't see another mirror where
I could get an angle to it
that's the only one for oh don't tell me
I actually Oh what I thought I hit that
one like way to go oh okay
ah that was my mistake I thought that
when I reflected it and got those uh
that big pink one over there to move I
thought that's what happened when I hit
it I did I did not realize that that was
sorry I'm stupid hurry if you keep
stupid there we go
triple shot now that I actually think
that I haven't progressed or I know that
I haven't progressed I actually can
progress sorry everybody
I apologize for my unprofessionalism I'm
coming for you kid hang on I got you
yeah I am I didn't know this who is this
monster for a second there I thought
that I might have been the monster
because I've been the monster in many a
game before perhaps we all are Mon ok
enough now it's interesting because I
it's been oh my god you gotta be kidding
me
I can't it's been actually it's been
literally years since I did a video
without a webcam like the last thing
that I did without a webcam was probably
Dishonored
what so I imagine that we're in a
hospital and people are actually talking
around us and we can hear them just bits
and pieces but anyway what I was saying
is I haven't done a good er okay not
that way sorry Co easy to make mistakes
I saw I saw panels where were the I
thought I saw broken panels didn't I
yeah there we go there we are okay
broken broken broken broken broken
broken broken what they're all broken
how does that help me in the world am I
supposed to do if they're all broken
it's mirror they're uh bounced that way
maybe I okay what missed it come on
almost not come on there we go got it
ding dong ding dong ding dong all right
so that allowed me to get past all the
broken crap and now I just got to get
through these things if my mouse will
cooperate that one's gonna go I'm too
smart for you don't try to dissuade me
from my destination I'm really glad that
I I picked up the rabbit and beginning I
hate to see if I actually mistrusted it
uh okay I think I heard ringing under
the floor what do you mean ringing under
the floor whoa there another okay god
this mouse is just driving me absolutely
nuts I really wish that I had a better
mouse right now but I do not
ding dong ah wait I saw that that
stopped twitching you Mouse
there we go it's one okay I don't think
I'm supposed to do those yet okay so I
got it I just got to get this to go
somehow I got to get this come on there
we go
oh why wasn't i standing on those that
would have been incredibly helpful but
as you see it does not help me oh this
one does okay oh those those those okay
ah got it got it got it got it okay
that's what it meant I wouldn't have
been able to see those if I hadn't
already uh gotten the thing done there
so I did not mess up yeah it's it's an
odd experience and I imagine that a lot
of people are faster reservoir is no
webcam I mean I know that I'm incredibly
devilishly outrageously handsome however
it comes a time when you have to do
whatever it takes okay I gotta get this
one I swear the voices are coming from
everywhere around me and not where I'm
looking okay that was one thing wait did
I actually get that oh I saw that did I
get that I don't know if that's actually
a ding dong where is it to go I wish
there was some sort of confirmation like
it stayed lit when I actually did
something worth doing that would be too
helpful for me okay so where am I going
I need to find a way oh this is my right
is my right
god it's so disorienting I wish that I
could express my confusion and more than
the words that I have in my brain wait
you weren't even making a sound oh sorry
how would I have been able to find you
okay that's a good strategy but I don't
think that it's gonna work in this place
cuz I got dang it no no no okay geez you
gotta calm down there game your mouse
it's the mouse it's not the game it's
the mouse my mouse is just freaking out
I why did I buy a five buck one oh wait
no no no no that's wrong I needed no no
no no no no Oh No there's another way to
go ah but not that way I fell I fell I'm
an idiot please kill me thank you
now where did you drop me off okay over
here so um there is a way I need to get
to that one which rides off of this
platform up over there to that other one
who is not making a sound it's not very
helpful for me to find you if you're not
seeing anything little children
uncle markiplier will finally come
rescue you no no no my ride my ride my
ride oh I made it I'm so pro I made it
Bing bong okay whoa stop God that is so
annoying especially in this game I
couldn't have asked for a worse game to
have that happen god it did it again did
you see it okay
What did he say I have no idea
ow my leg I hope you guys heard that
because that hurt quite a bit come on
hurry up your butt I ain't got places to
be like that white area I seriously
don't know how much longer this game is
gonna take but hopefully not too oh you
missed you meant yeah uh is this a leap
of faith do I have to brag okay made it
oh okay
what the oh okay look alright hello hi
hey am i ah that didn't explain anything
that was completely ha that didn't say
anything about what was actually
happening was it just the coma was the
only experience I was there actually
something to beat was there actually
something evil going on I have no idea
and that didn't explain anything ah well
there you have it that's a lot of people
for this game those it was actually
really interesting experience mostly
because uh what did I just do anyway
this has been Devil's tuning fork I'm
sorry that I didn't have my webcam but
then again I think it kind of added to
the experience like you were guided by
my voice the only tool that you had was
your ears had your eyes for seeing the
video but that's besides boy anyway
thank you all so much for watching all
hey I'll have everything back to 100%
I'm still in the transition phase of my
move to LA but I am pretty fairly
established so thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will se you
or hear you in the next video bye bye
your mother was it go to your mother it
was your mother because one or the other
depends on whether I should go to her or
not or run oh heck you gotta be more
clear I know you've been drowning in a
washing machine that note why are you
chief became family hi